yep the road is so small today
recently on Instagram I asked my
followers to give me their phone number
if we had never met
so today I'm just gonna go ahead and
call them all right here we go
[Music]
hello hi
it's Riya yes yes this is the Riya by
the way yeah this is Riya
yeah what's your name what's your name
what's your name what's your name where
are you from to start I'll just let you
kind of tell me about yourself
and you could include anything okay so
I'll get right into the hard questions
if you don't mind my first question for
you is the question I've asked on my
channel before and that's what's the
hardest thing you've ever been through
I don't know I think they actually took
the first place would have been alive it
would have been a chance or something at
the same time you know everything
happens for a reason so yeah how old are
you know how old are you at the time 16
15
I I'm sorry because I just yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we're all in the boughs we could
talk to as well
hi good what's your name
so hey that's my sister's name I have so
many questions for you because you just
you have such a unique life I feel like
what's been your kindest act I think
it's yeah but then what is the bird
thing
I kept running after it and then I found
out that it was a small bird with a
broken wing soit's
home kenefick students face like a big
small stick it's like you made like a
like this probably like a stick in the
string kind of you wrapped it around or
something yeah and that was I think I
don't buy having grown up with like like
as an American and and as an Egyptian do
you kind of find conflict between like a
traditional conservative life and like
more modern their judgments like people
don't major wherever you want for
example if you have a nephew or or if
you're a guy that has a piercing or it
has like really long hair people look at
you differently if you have our
represented Dean's people look at you
differently
now if you speak in foreign language
people people make fun of me and I was
about it
you know because I was just different so
right I want you to describe to me what
it what if what it's like to be you like
in terms of feelings like not in terms
of like I don't want you to describe
like oh I'm 21 this is my major but like
if you could make someone feel what it's
like to be you how would you how would
you do that for me was really really
really hard I do look what you said
about me says something like no one can
feel what it's like to be you yeah you
go through experiences the cheap you to
who you are plus the way you think plus
your soul which reacts the stuff which
feels stuff that puts passes and
if you decide to take what what you pass
to take to get to that Spanish [ __ ] for
life just like support [ __ ] your buddy
Wow okay that's that's good that's the
quote of the day for sure okay I have to
steal that from you all right you want
to hear something funny
[Music]
so I made I think your v phone call I
made and at the end of each phone call
I've told people to kind of give me
their any thoughts and I followed it by
followed it up by giving them my ending
thoughts and I ended every single
conversation by telling them my favorite
quote recently which is strangers are
just friends you haven't met yet and so
the first three people I've said that to
at the end and then the fourth guy
called was like an amazing phone call
the phone call acid in an hour and I
asked them okay so what are your ending
thoughts and as she was saying it I was
like okay thinking to myself like okay
after he's done I'm gonna tell my
favorite quote and then he ends his
ending thoughts by saying and also
strangers are just friends you haven't
met yet and I just about lost it like I
think I scared him because I
so yeah so the best part was I went to
turn off my camera and I realized that
the mic was off the entire time so yeah
[Music]
before I asked the last question
you're a really interesting guy I'm like
I'm afraid that I didn't ask the right
question so is there anything else about
you that you wanna share I got to a face
and some part of my life where I didn't
care about anyone I didn't hear about
myself anything
I just did whatever I wanted to so yeah
just so you know I loved our
conversation you sound like a really
cool guy
some of the things that you've been
through like I can't even fathom like I
can't imagine going through that we all
we all have our stories huh it's so cool
that you're watching my videos from
Egypt and like you have such a cool
background and having you like a person
like you say that you like my work it
makes
not much better showing how beautiful
people people are not you not the way
they live but just from the inside
speaking and their smile and and
everything you know that's that's just
so inspiring it it actually makes me
together to be depressed you know you
have your times when you get like really
depressed if you don't want to talk to
anyone you don't want to interact with
any sort of person but you know I just
hope my phone sit down for a bit maybe
your video pops up or something I know
it just makes me feel better
so thank you for them and thank you for
calling me I appreciate it that's the
reason why I do this I'm sure we'll talk
again you are connected on Instagram now
and hopefully we'll be in person at some
point yeah I think that's pretty much it
Thank You Mohammad okay thank you so
much how about have a good day okay look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys for watching this episode
if you want to possibly get a phone call
for me in the future when I do another
episode like this make sure to find me
on Instagram and direct message me your
phone number make sure not to tell me
anything about yourself because I want
it to feel like I'm calling a stranger
so please send me your phone number and
you might possibly get a phone call for
me in the future also please make sure
to hit the subscribe button if you enjoy
watching my episodes and maybe share an
episode with the friend who you think
would enjoy them as well